LET IT REST AND GET BACK TO 100%
NEXT YEAR.
I WAS ABLE TO DO WHAT I NEEDED
TO DO ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
>> IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
SUPER BOWL LVII WAS MEMORABLE
AND HISTORIC FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
ONE OF THEM IS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN THE NFL THAT BOTH
STARTING QUARTERBACKS WERE
BLACK.
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT JUST
ROOTED IN SOME REALLY BAD
UNFAIRNESS IN NFL HISTORY.
BUT BEYOND THAT, WHAT DID IT
MEAN TO YOU?
DID YOU AND JALEN HURTS, THE
QUARTERBACK FOR THE EAGLES, DID
YOU TALK ABOUT IT AT ALL?
>> IT WAS TALKED ABOUT FOR SURE.
IT WAS A SPECIAL MOMENT.
I WAS GLAD THAT THE GAME WENT
THE WAY IT WENT, EVEN THOUGH IT
MADE ME A LITTLE NERVOUS AT THE
END.
BUT JALEN PLAYED HIS TAIL OFF,
MAN.
ALL RESPECT TO HIM.
IT SHOWED THAT THE BLACK
QUARTERBACK -- WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO DO, CAN GO OUT AND HAVE
SUCCESS ON THE WORLD STAGE IN
THE BIGGEST GAME OF THEM ALL.
WE'RE STANDING ON THE SHOULDERS
OF DOUG HARRIS, WARREN MOON,
SHAQ HARRIS, ALL THE GREATS.
THEY GAVE US THIS PLATFORM AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN INSPIRE SOME
KIDS TO FOLLOW THEIR DREAM AND
BE A QUARTERBACK IN THE FUTURE
WHENEVER WE'RE SITTING ON THE
COUCH WATCHING A SUPER BOWL.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT FAITH A LOT.
I'M WONDERING WHAT'S THE BEST
WAY YOU THINK YOUR FAITH PLAYS A
ROLE IN YOUR GAME?
IS IT BRINGING YOU A PEACE?
DOES IT BRING YOU A PERSPECTIVE?
HOW DOES IT HELP YOU?
>> IT'S DEFINITELY PERSPECTIVE I
THINK TO ME.
I DO A LOT OF JUST THINKING
ABOUT GOING OUT THERE AND
PLAYING TO GLORIFY HIM.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WINNING AND
LOSING EVEN THOUGH IT IS IN OUR
WORLD.
BUT IT'S TO GO OUT THERE AND
LEAVE EVERYTHING I HAVE ON THE
FIELD TO SHOW THAT I'M
GLORIFYING HIM.
IT GIVES ME PERSPECTIVE TO LEAVE
EVERYTHING OUT THERE AND K